So every Christmas, you've
probably heard this really
powerful comparison that the
story of Jesus, Mary, and Joseph
is actually a story about
refugees.
It's a way to connect this
ancient story to some very
modern and often very heated
political debates.
In this explainer, we're going
to unpack the history behind
that very claim.
You've likely seen some version
of this argument before.
I mean, it's a really sharp,
compelling claim.
It frames the whole nativity
story as a case of asylum
seeking with King Herod playing
the part of a border agent.
It's a super effective
rhetorical tool, for sure.
But the question is, is it
historically accurate?
Let's take a look.
All right, so if we're going to
test this analogy, we can't
really start with our world and
our laws.
No, we have to start with
theirs.
We've got to understand the
political and legal reality of
the world the Holy Family
actually lived in, and that
world, for all intents and
purposes, it was the Roman
Empire.
And look, this isn't just some
random background detail, it is
the single most important piece
of context for understanding
their entire journey.
This right here is the
foundational point.
Joseph, Mary and Jesus were not
leaving 1 sovereign nation and
trying to get into another.
They were moving between two
different regions, Judea and
Egypt, but both of them were
firmly inside the same massive
political system, Rome.
This comparison really gets to
the heart of it.
A Roman subject living in Judea
was not considered a foreigner
in Egypt.
They belong to the system.
So all these modern ideas like
unlawful presence or illegal
entry, they just didn't apply to
someone moving within the
empire's own boundaries.
So you see, once you understand
this, that it was all one single
empire, it completely reframes
the nature of their flight.
This analogy is just incredibly
clarifying, isn't it?
They were fleeing a local
tyrant, Herod, by moving to a
different jurisdiction that was
under the same big overarching
authority.
It was an internal relocation.
Yeah, it was driven by a
terrible threat, but it wasn't
an international border
crossing.
Now, this doesn't mean Rome was
a world Without Borders.
Oh, no.
It absolutely had them.
And they were often violently
enforced.
You had legions patrolling the
Rhine, the Danube.
But, and this is so key that
enforcement was pointed outwards
at non subjects, at outsiders
trying to get in.
So the crucial point is that the
Holy Family never had to face
that kind of external border
guard.
Now, if they had been fleeing
from the neighboring Parthian
Empire into Roman Judea, that's
a whole different story.
Then they would have been
treated as foreigners trying to
get in.
But they were already inside the
club, so to speak.
All this historical context
actually points us toward a much
more precise modern legal
category to describe their
situation, one that actually
helps clarify things instead of
confusing them.
Let's look at the modern,
internationally accepted
definition of a refugee.
You see that critical part?
You have to cross an
international border.
You have to leave your country
and enter another one.
OK, now compare that to this
category, the internally
displaced person, or IDP.
And IDP is someone who flees for
the exact same reasons,
Persecution, violence.
But they do it without ever
leaving their own country.
They just relocate within its
borders.
And these American examples,
wow, they really illustrate the
concept perfectly.
People who fled the Dust Bowl or
the horrific violence of the Jim
Crow South were absolutely
escaping life threatening
conditions.
Their suffering was immense.
But legally, because they moved
from, say, Oklahoma to
California or from Mississippi
to Chicago, they were considered
internal migrants, not refugees.
So when you apply this modern
legal framework to the
historical facts, the conclusion
is pretty direct.
The Holy Family's flight from
Herod perfectly fits the
definition of internal
displacement.
They were fleeing a threat from
within their own political
system.
Now you might be thinking, OK,
refugee IDP.
Are we just splitting hairs?
What's the big deal?
Well, this distinction is
actually crucial if we want to
have a clear conversation about
what the story means for us
today.
Think about it like this.
Our modern debates about
immigration are built on this
huge, complex legal
architecture.
We're talking asylum,
deportation, sovereignty.
None of that really existed for
someone moving from one Roman
province to another.
So trying to impose these modern
ideas onto the nativity story
is, well, it's like trying to
fit a square peg in a round
hole.
We're projecting our world back
onto theirs, and that really
gets to the heart of the matter.
This isn't about diminishing the
suffering of the Holy Family or
the moral power of their story
at all.
It's about insisting on
historical accuracy so that we
can have honest debates using
precise terms, rather than using
analogies that are emotionally
powerful but historically just
don't quite fit.
Ultimately, this brings us to a
bigger question.
The Holy Family's Flight is,
without a doubt a powerful story
about surviving a violent
threat.
But by grounding it in its
actual historical context, it
forces us to think a little more
carefully about how we use the
past to talk about the present.
What changes when we swap out a
flawed metaphor for a more
precise history?
Now that's a question worth
thinking about.